bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
France 24 la France compte quelques 6000
entreprises familiales et le principal
danger qui les menace n'est ni l'État ni
le chaos de l'économie mais bien souvent
des mésententes entre héritier si le
sujet de la transmission à nourrit la
littérature ou les séries télévisées ou
le cinéma la réalité dépasse parfois la
fiction c'est ce que révèle l'enquête de
Raphaël baquet et Vanessa Schneider
d'abord publié sous la forme d'une série
dans le quotidien Le Monde le récit des
grandes familles du capitalisme français
et désormais réunis dans un ouvrage
succession l'argent le sang et les
larmes aux éditions allemands Michel
Rafael baquet bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors au coeur
de votre travail ce sont des histoires
de succession mais pas n'importe
lesquelles il s'agit des pinots des deux
co Hermès mulliès Peugeot ce sont des
noms qui sont bien connus en France mais
également à l'étranger comme du temps
des rois de France ou des empereurs il y
a une obsession c'est comment
transmettre comment faire lorsque le
royaume que l'empire leur survivent et
ça passe souvent par un choix crucial
c'est celui de trouver le bon héritier
au sein de la famille oui c'est
particulièrement difficile parce que il
faut non seulement le former mais il
faut être capable de lui céder le
pouvoir et c'est souvent ça qui retient
ses grands patriarches qui sont parfois
ceux qui ont fondé ces grands groupes
Bernard Arnault a littéralement fondé et
fait fructifier LVMH François Pinot
c'est la même chose et donc pour eux
être capable de de céder la place de
trouver au sein de de leurs enfants
celui qui va pouvoir les dépasser d'une
certaine façon et et et faire
transmettre le nom et le faire briller
ça c'est effectivement difficile et sont
souvent ambivalents là-dessus Bernard
Arnault vous voyez justement derrière
vous entouré de ses enfants réussir sa
succession c'est aussi bien gérer les
rancœurs que peuvent susciter ce choix
en fait ce qui nous a frappé c'est que
c'est pas tellement une histoire
d'argent c'est beaucoup une histoire de
psychologie beaucoup une histoire
d'affectent la France règle les
problèmes d'argent vous ne pouvez pas
déshériter vos enfants au bénéfice d'un
droit voilà d'un aîné par exemple donc
le la loi règle ça et d'ailleurs tant
mieux ça évite des déchirements
supplémentaires mais en fait ce qui
reste c'est quel est le choix que vous
allez faire est-ce que c'est l'enfant
préféré est-ce que c'est le plus
intelligent est-ce que c'est celui qui
vous ressemble et ça c'est très
difficile et on voit bien que les
fratries peuvent être animées par des
rivalités sanglantes des pères peuvent
avoir du mal à choisir un fils ou à se
voir dépasser par lui et c'est ce qui
nous a frappé dans tous ces grands
groupes c'est qu'au fond ça l'affectent
la psychologie la capacité à transmettre
sans violence
c'est déterminant pour la survie de ces
groupes et souvent des milliers
d'emplois qui ils sont à très bien ils
sont derrière très très conscients du
fait que c'est déchirements ou ses
rancœurs familial elles peuvent
affaiblir le groupe on se souvient d'un
Bernard Arnault qui profitait de
l'affaiblissement au sein du clan Hermès
pour rentrer subrepticement au sein du
capital en rachetant précisément les
parts d'héritier qui pouvaient sentir
écartés au sein d'Hermès oui Bernard
Arnault est sans doute celui qui a le
meilleur fortune mondiale oui première
fortune mondiale et il a constitué son
groupe
en rachetant des des entreprises à des
familles qui justement n'étaient pas
réussi à s'accorder donc c'est ce qu'il
a fait avec Récamier qui est la base
LVMH c'est ce qu'il a tenté de faire
avec Hermès et sa chance là il est celui
qui a
conçu le plus scientifiquement possible
la formation de ses propres enfants
c'est très frappant il en a cinq de deux
mariages différents avoir deux mariages
un divorce et un hors mariage dans les
familles c'est une source de
de déchirement et dissension très
classique alors évidemment il a organisé
l'entente entre ses enfants les cinq
enfants sont dans le groupe il n'a pas
encore décidé qui vraiment lui succédera
mais ils sont tous à des postes clés et
il les a formés dans cette perspective
il est difficile d'ailleurs d'échapper à
la volonté d'un homme comme Bernard
Arnault Il y a un autre exemple qui est
assez frappant c'est celui de Vincent
Bolloré qui lui justement a remodeler
son empire pour ramener ses enfants vers
lui qui avait pu s'en détourner à la
suite d'un divorce oui il avait divorcé
et il est parti d'ailleurs avec sa
belle-sœur c'est à dire la tente de ses
enfants et donc il a vécu avec les
cousins de ses enfants ça c'est mortel
dans une famille et effectivement ses
fils c'était éloignés de lui et sa fille
et puis pour les ramener dans son giron
il a rendu son groupe plus désirable
pour eux et c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
c'est souvent on oublie ça mais ça
façonné sa stratégie c'est à dire que
c'est ainsi qu'il a conce réorienté son
groupe vers les médias qui étaient plus
séduisants pour ses enfants et qui les a
fait revenir auprès de lui alors selon
l'adage bien connu la première
génération crée la seconde guerre et la
troisième tue c'est une prophétie qui
s'est réalisée parfois sans attendre la
troisième génération on pense au cas
Lagardère oui c'est vrai là on a
vraiment le cas d'un enfant qui est mal
élevé c'est à dire que son père est très
brillant Jean-Luc Lagardère
écrasant c'est un homme qui se conçoit
comme un héros il disait très souvent
qu'est-ce que John Wayne aurait fait à
ma place donc c'est vous dire à quel
point effectivement il se considère
comme un super héros et il va priver son
fils à l'âge de 11 ans de sa mère il va
le fragiliser d'une certaine façon il va
compenser ce vide affectif par un déluge
d'argent et ça c'est un des problèmes
métier ne pas succomber de ne pas être
ensevelie sous l'argent qui évidemment
dénature tout et c'est ainsi que Arnaud
Lagardère qui a pourtant plus de 40 ans
quand son père meurt accidentellement
n'est pas prêt à prendre la suite
d'ailleurs tout le groupe l'appelle
encore junior et au fond il n'a eu de
cesse presque c'est presque un cas de
psychanalyse que de détruire ce groupe
et de démanteler ce groupe que son père
avait constitué alors à l'inverse il y a
l'exemple d'une transmission totalement
réussie c'est celle peut-être même le
plus de la famille la plus discrète
c'est la famille Mulliez des enseignes
comme Auchan Decathlon ou Leroy Merlin
pour eux alors pas question d'entrer en
bourse mais il y a une sorte de pacte
d'actionnaires très particulier il parle
de communisme actionnarial et aussi la
gestion du groupe se fait toujours faire
des entreprises se fait toujours en
tandem alors eux ils ont une difficulté
particulière c'est qu'ils sont très
nombreux est-ce qu'on en est à la 8e
génération donc ils sont plus de 1000
héritiers quand vous avez 1000 héritiers
évidemment c'est très compliqué donc ils
ont organisé ça d'une main de fer les
conjoints ont le droit d'avoir des
actions mais s'il y a divorce ils
doivent les rendre et ce qu'ils veulent
qu'ils veulent rentrer dans le groupe
doivent passer devant un espèce de jury
qui est constitué des oncles les tentes
de leurs parents éventuellement et c'est
vraiment un défi où le le groupe passe
avant les liens familiaux c'est-à-dire
ce sont les gens de la famille qui sont
là mais c'est d'abord le bien du groupe
qui est pris en compte il y a un autre
cas qui est aux antipodes d'une certaine
façon c'est celui de Jérôme Seydoux
alors lui il refuse clairement
d'envisager sa succession et même d'une
certaine façon il sacrifie un à un ces
héritiers c'est dauphins pourtant qu'il
semble désigner c'est quoi
psychologiquement comment on explique ça
ils veulent détruire l'empire après lui
après l'huile en politique c'est un
autocrate un autocrate quelqu'un qui
n'imagine personne à sa hauteur il est
d'ailleurs exceptionnellement
intelligent et il a fait de son groupe
de cinéma de salle notamment de
distribution un groupe important mais
alors qu'il a 8 enfants
personne effectivement ne lui paraît
susceptible de le remplacer d'ailleurs
il les a fait il ne les a pas fait
rentrer dans le groupe il ne les a pas
formés et même lorsqu'il a choisi des
directeurs généraux qui n'étaient pas de
sa famille à chaque fois que cela était
près du pouvoir il les a éliminés
impitoyablement on appelle ça d'ailleurs
au sein du groupe Pathé les exécutions
capitales c'est pour vous dire et
effectivement probablement que le groupe
sera vendu avec sa mort à sa mort il dit
d'ailleurs très clairement qu'il veut
mourir sur scène comme Molière qu'est-ce
que ça te dit tous ces exemples du
capitalisme français c'est quoi c'est un
modèle familial très masculin on voit
que les femmes sont amenées à jouer à ce
gros rôle est-ce que ces choses sont en
train de bouger oui alors il y a un
effet de génération chez tous ces hommes
qui sont encore à la tête de ces grands
groupes très puissants ce sont des
septures génères à tout le monde donc
effectivement très souvent les filles
n'étaient pas leurs priorité d'ailleurs
François Pinot dit il a une fille aînée
voilà succession donc vraiment si vous
dire mais dans la génération suivante
les filles sont là chez les deux co
l'une des filles la fille de
Jean-François l'un des nés de la fratrie
est dans le dans le groupe et elle va
probablement être une des dirigeantes du
groupe les filles de la génération de
30-40 ans sont très diplômés aujourd'hui
elles ont envie de diriger et il y a
beaucoup moins de de
blocage qu'il ne pouvait y en avoir dans
la génération précédente comment on
enquête précisément dans ce milieu très
discret de la de la bourgeoisie voire de
l'aristocratie industrielle c'est
particulièrement difficile car c'est un
milieu où on est ses grands patrons sont
entourés d'une armada d'avocat être
conseiller en communication donc
évidemment qu'ils veulent bien faire de
la com sur leur groupe mais il parle
très rarement de leur secret de famille
or là on avait souvent l'impression
d'être un peu Freud au sein du
capitalisme français puisque ce qui nous
intéressait c'était justement les
relations affectives qui déterminent
après le management et ça c'est très
souvent quelque chose qui est caché dans
les familles on a beaucoup enquêté
directement auprès des principaux
intéressés de l'entourage c'est bien sûr
de l'entourage les hauts cadres de ces
groupes regardent ça avec comme
autrefois la nomenclatura analysait et
le moindre mouvement au sein du Kremlin
si vous voulez donc bien sûr que très
souvent les hauts cadres de ces groupes
ont une connaissance très fine des
familles et c'est ce qui nous a
intéressé merci beaucoup en tout cas
Raphaël baquet merci pour cette plongée
au coeur du capitalisme familial
familial français merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi l'information continue sur
France 24
[Musique]